hello my name is Michael a extra man
with sass the analytical company one of
the big questions here in Davos these
years how can we ensure inclusive growth
and I might actually be closed down
during but our ability sort side what is
the next big thing behind on after the
internet so we've seen the growth of big
data and big data columns the ability to
accelerate innovation to drive
innovation that will require inclusive
growth I think we can all have
productivity gains 257 percent but above
that we need to accelerate innovation we
need to draw in the collective knowledge
and that's about sweeping the large
volumes of data that exists out there
social media data structure data
unstructured data to help us accelerate
the growth to to narrow the gap between
individual knowledge and the collective
knowledge